Do you wonder what it would be like to compete
in squid game? Well now you can find out what the
JavaScript game you create yourself using three
js. In this tutorial Shubho teaches you how to
create a game from squid game with a 3d model.
Today I have a really exciting project for you
guys, we are going to create the red light green
light game from the series quit game. So if you
haven't watched that series, yet, the way this
game works is you have this doll, and you are
given a specific amount of time. And in that time,
you have to move from this corner to this corner.
But the catch is you can only move when she's not
looking at you. If you try to move when she looks
forward, you will be eliminated. So let's see
that in action. So if I refresh the game, we'll
start the game has started and we can move, we can
press arrow key to move. But if we try to move on,
she's looking forward. As you can see, it says we
lost. So that's rules. Let's try to win this game.
And there we have won the game. So this is a
really exciting project. I hope you're equally
excited as I am. So make sure you like the video
if you haven't already yet. And let's get started.
Okay, to create this game, we're going to be using
three js three. JS is a JavaScript 2d library, it
uses web GL to render graphics on the canvas. This
is really powerful and easy to get started. So if
you have no experience with three js, don't worry,
because we'll be doing a lot of copy pasting from
the documentation. And I'll be going over the
course briefly. Okay, so let me close this window.
And in my file explorer, as you can see,
I've created a folder called squid game that
will we'll be working on this folder. So let's
open it up with VS code. So click on Open with
VS code. And now we're going to create the index
dot HTML file. So let's say index dot HTML.
And we're also going to create two folder one is
js for the JavaScript file, and one is CSS for the
CSS file. So CSS like so. Now in the CSS, let's
created style dot CSS file. So let's say style
dot CSS, and in the JavaScript, we'd need a
main.js file. So new file, main dot J's. So
now they're seeing them in our HTML. First, let's
create the basic markup. Let me close the sidebar
CTRL V to close the sidebar, exclamation mark tab,
and it will create the basic boilerplate here,
let's link our stylesheet. So let's say link.
And Asia rep will be CSS for slash style dot CSS.
Also link our JavaScript. So let's say script
source equals to j s forward slash main.js.
Like so. And let me open it up with our live
server. So click on Open with live server.
And it will open in localhost colon 5500. Okay,
now we want to use three J's in our project.
So let's download the three J's. So go to go to
your chrome and search for three js GitHub. And
the first link will take you to the GitHub page of
ujs. So from here, click on the Build button, and
then click on the three dot main dot j s. So dot
mean basically means is the compressed version,
it will load faster. Now click on the roll button.
After that, you can click CTRL S to save it.
And we want to save it in our project
folder. So navigate to your project folder,
go to the JavaScript folder and when to save
it as three dot main dot j, so click on save.
Okay, now if we if we open up our sidebar, and
in the JavaScript folder, we'll see we have the
three dot main dot j. So let's let's link that
file. So we're going to say script source equals
to j s four slash three dot main dot j s like so.
Okay, now let's go to the three js documentation
page. And here, click on the documentation.
And in the documentation page, you will see
we have a lot of course that we can copy paste
to get started. So let me copy all this course
Ctrl C, and paste it CTRL V, like so. Let me close
the sidebar again. And now if you go to our page,
you will see we have this blank canvas.
So let's see what's happening. So first,
we're creating a new scene by saying New three
dot scene. So scene is basically what we see.
To see it we need a camera. So in the second line,
we're creating a new camera by saying New three
dot perspective camera. So we have many types of
camera, the perspective camera is most basic. So
the documentation if we search for that, there
is a perspective camera as you can see that the
perspective camera takes four arguments, the
fob, the aspect, the near and far. So this will
make sense if you're into photograph graphy or
camera. Otherwise, you can leave this default,
this will work just fine. Then we're creating
a renderer. So the renderer is what is used to
render all the graphics in our canvas.
Then we're saying render dot set size,
and passing window dot inner width
and window inner height. So basically,
we're saying the renderer should be the size of
our window. And then the rendered DOM element
will give us the canvas and we're appending that
Canvas to our document body. So if we save this,
we get this blank canvas and but we
have this little whitespace on left,
top and left. So let's try to remove that in
the CSS. So let's say target everything. And
we're going to say the margin should be zero
and padding should be zero. So margin zero,
and the padding can also be zero. If we save this
as you can see, now the whitespace is gone. Okay.
Now let's try to add a shape in our scene. So
let's see. Let's go back to the recommendation.
So if we scroll down, actually if you go back
and then scroll down as you can We have some more
code. So let me copy all of them again Ctrl C ctrl
v. So first, we're creating a box geometry. So in
3d world, the shapes are basically geometric, we
have many types of geometry, we have box geometry,
we have sphere geometry, you have cylinder
geometry, we have polygon, etc. So the box is
the basic geometry, we use Box geometry to create
cubes. So a geometry is made out of triangles or
vertices. So we need to wrap our geometry ins
with a material. So there are many types of
materials. But for now, we just want to give it
a color. So we're using the MeSH basic materials,
which is basically just a color. So we're
specifying the color here. And then we're creating
the mesh by combining the geometry and materials
here. And finally, we have to add that cube to
our scene. So we're saying scene dot add cube.
So if you now save it, and open up the browser,
open up that in browser, as you can see, we can
see that is because every time we add something
to our scene, or update something, we have to call
the renderer dot render function, and we have to
pass the scene on camera. So now if we save it, as
you can see, now we can see this, see the cubes.
Now by saying camera dot position dot z equals to
five, we were basically specifying how far from
the scene should be on camera. So if I were to
make it make the number smaller, now the camera
is more near to the scene, so it appears bigger
if we're to make it bigger. Now the camera is more
fat, so this object appears to be smaller. So, so
five is a good number. So let's leave it at five.
So every time we add a shape to our scene,
or update anything, we have to call the
renderer dot render function, but manually calling
this can be a pain, which is why we use this code,
this block of code. So let me copy this and then
I will explain to you and paste it here. So first,
we're creating the animate function in the animate
function, we are calling the renderer dot render,
and we're passing scene and camera. So let me
just move it down. I like to, I like to put it
in the in the very bottom, but it doesn't matter
really. Okay, so what is happening in the request
animation frame, we're passing the animate
function. So what the request animation frame
will do is call the animate function again and
again. So if I were to console log something here,
so whereas if I say console dot log Hello world,
and in the browser, if I now open the console,
you will see hello world is being printed again
and again. So basically, the animate function
will be called again and again. So now we
don't have to manually call this function
called our renderer dot render function here.
Okay, now let's look at some animations,
we can animate our cube, so let's try to animate
our cube. So in the animate function, we can say
something like you've got rotation, cube dot
rotation, oops, cube dot rotation, that x plus
equals 2.01. So basically, you keep increasing
the rotation dot x. So if we now save it,
as you can see, our cube is now rotating in the x
axis, if we were to say rotation dot y, it would
rotate in the Z axis, if we had to say rotation,
but it's it, it will rotate in the Z axis. So the
number basically specifying how fast it should
rotate, so if we were to make it point five,
now it is faster if we were to make it
even smaller. Now it is rotating very,
very slowly. Okay, let me remove this group code.
And let me remove this actual it, just comment it
comment this out for now, so we don't want the
cube. Instead, what I want is the doll. So how
we can create the doll. So so in the SketchUp,
I have found this 3d model of the doll. So this
guy created it, and he is allowing us to use it
for free, so you just have to create an account
in SketchUp. After that, you can click on download
3d model and download the glTF version. So click
on Download, and it will start downloading it. By
the way, I will leave the link to this page in the
video description. And I'll also leave the link
to the finished code in the video description.
So you will be able to get everything from
there. So if you decide to follow along
and get stuck, you can refer to that code. Okay,
let's wait for this to finish. Okay, the download
is now complete, so we can right click and click
on show in folder. And then I'm going to click on
extract files. And let's say the folder name
should be models. So let me rename this to models.
So now this the file has been
extracted in this model folder.
Here we have all the files.
So let me click on the Cut.
And let's put it in our project folder. So So my
project is in www folder. And then inside duck
squid Game dot and I'm going to paste the folder
here, so click on paste. And we can close the file
explorer now and close this tab. And if we open
up our sidebar again, you see we have now had
this Models folder inside that we have the files
for the 3d model. So now let's see how we can
use the 3d model with three js. Okay, if I go to
the documentation page again and search for glTF.
Here you see the glTF loader click on this.
And this again gives us some example on how
we can load a 3d model. So let me copy
this, copy this line of code. So Ctrl C,
and Ctrl V. So first, we are creating a new glTF
loader model. But to be able to use this glTF
loader, we have to first add it to our JavaScript.
So again, go to the three js GitHub page
And then click, click on the examples.
And then the and then click on JavaScript
folder. After that, go to the loaders.
And here you will see the glTF loader. So click on
that. And again, we can click on the roll button
and press Ctrl S to Save it. So where to save it
as glTF loader dot j s to save. As you can see
that glTF loader has been added to our project. So
let's link it in our JavaScript also. So let's in
our HTML also, so let's say script source equals
to this time it will be j s forward slash glTF
loader dot j s, like so. Now this lead here would
have worked if we were to install the glTF loader
with NPM and imported it. But since you're using
since we're using the regular script file, instead
of just saying glTF loader, we have to say 3d
glTF loader so simply say three dot glTF loader.
And now this should work. Let's see what next
we have to do. So after that, we have to call
the loader dot load function to load our 3d
model. So let's do that. So we can say loader
loader dot load. And here we have to, we have
to specify the path to our 3d model. So our 3d
models file is in the Models folder. After that,
we have the scene dot glTF. So let's say dot dot
forward slash. Since we are in the JavaScript
folder, we have to go one folder up then in the
Models folder. So that's why we're saying dot
dot forward slash models. And then we're going
to say scene scene dot glTF. Now this loader
dot load function will load this glTF. And once
the loader is loaded, we will have a callback
function executed. So this callback function.
So let's create the body of this function here
so that this callback function will receive the
loaded glTF. So let's call it glTF. And then we
can say scene dot add glTF dot scene. And now if
we save it, and go to the project, as you can see,
we can see nothing. Let's see, why is that let's
open up our console. So we don't have any error,
but we still can see it that is because currently
in our scene, we don't have any light, we need
a light to be able to see objects or models.
So let's add some light. So again, let's go
to the documentation and search for light.
In three js, again, we have various type of light,
but the most basic light is the ambient light. So
click on the ambient light. And let's copy this
code again. And let's paste it. Let's say let's
paste it here. CTRL V. So first, we're creating
a new ambient light. And then here, here, we're
specifying the color of our light. In CSS, you
may have said hashtag 404040. But in JavaScript,
we simply say 0x, and then the code so this is the
code and we can delete this comment, we don't need
it. So now if we save this, and go back, and as
you can see, we have this doll. Okay, so let's
change the light color to white. So let's say FFF,
FFF. And now we can see the doll much clearer,
but the doll is very big. So let's scale it
down. So we're gonna say see glTF dot scene,
dot scale. So we're gonna call the scale function.
And we're gonna say dot scale dot set, we
have this called the set function to set
the scale. Okay, now since we are in
a 3d world, we have three dimensions.
And let's say we want to scale it to 0.4 on all
dimensions, so let's say point four point 4.4
likes and now if we save it, it should be scaled.
So it's the spelling is SCA. Now if we save it,
as you can see, now the dollar is a lot
smaller but but one problem you'll see
is if I try to resize my screen, as you can
see that square Canvas does not resize. Okay,
let's try to make this responsive to make this
responsive. We're going to use this block of
code. So let's see what's happening. So first,
we're saying window dot add event listener.
We're listening for the resize event, and
we're calling this function. So whenever
we will resize our screen. So if we resize our
screen, this function will be executed. And now
let's see what we're doing in this function. So
first, we're saying camera dot aspect equals to
window dot inner width divided by window dot inner
height since basically we have besides our screen,
now the aspect ratio of screen has been changed.
So now we are setting the aspect ratio to the new
aspect to the new aspect ratio of our screen.
And now since we have changed the aspect ratio,
we have to call the update projection matrix on
the camera. And finally, we have to say render dot
set size and to unset the size to the new window
dot inner width and windowed inner height or the
current in our width and height of our window. So
if we now save it, and now if we resize our window
as you can see now that Canvas also resizes. Okay,
now let's bring the door a bit down. So we can see
glTF so let's say glTF dot scene dot position dot
set. And here we can set the position in the X,
Y and the Z axis so we understand the position
in Z axis. So let's try one so if we say one,
it goes up but we don't need to come
down. So instead, we can use negative one.
And negative one should be good enough. Now
let's try to change the background color. So
to change the background color, we're going to
say renderer. So we can oops, to do that, we can
say renderer dot set clear color. So set clear car
car. And here we have to say this specify a color.
So I have already chosen a color, let me use
that. So the color I have chosen is B seven,
C, three, f three, if we now save it, as you
can see, now we have this bluish color. And
the second argument is basically the opacity of
the color. So you add one or full opacity, okay?
Now, instead of just loading this loading the
model like this, I want to create a new class
called doll. So we can have some methods
inside that class and easily call them. So
let's create a class called doll. So we
can say class doll. Inside that, we are
going to have a constructor function. So I can say
constructor. And let me cut all this code. So cut
and paste it here. CTRL V. So if we
now save this, that doll won't be
visible in the screen anymore. That is because
we have to create a new doll object. So let's
try to create a new doll object. So let's say let
doll equals to new doll. So now if you save it,
now again, we see this doll and also
where we I want to say this dot doll.
It should be doll because this glTF dot
scene so like so. So now we can have some
method in this class with a stick, let's
create a method called loopback. So look,
back, this will make the dog look at the backside.
So so in this function, we're gonna say dollar dot
rotation dot y to some value. So let's try one.
So now if we were to say dollar dot look back,
so dollar dot look back, let me call the function
and save it. And now if we look at our console,
you'll see we have some error that that is
saying cannot read properties of undefined.
So there is two reasons for
that. So first reason is,
it takes some time for our model to load. So let's
use a set timeout. So we can say set timeout.
And let's say we're going to call this function,
we're going to call the dollar. So we're going
to call that dollar look back after, let's say
one second. So 101,000 millisecond, if we save
this, we'll see we again have some error. So it is
saying cannot read properties of undefined. That
is because we have used the regular function here.
So if you use regular function, it creates its
own context. So now that now inside the function,
we're saying dot, this dot dollar, we're
saying this function dot ball, so we want this,
we want this to point to that this point to
this class, so we can use a regular function,
we're going to use an arrow function, like
so now, if we save this, after one second,
as you can see, that all rotates. So let's try,
those should rotate to let's say negative one.
And now let's try negative two. Okay, I think
negative 3.15 will make the doll look backward.
So now as you can see, if we call that look back
function that looks at backward, so we can also
have a doll dot look forward function. So we
can say look forward. We can say look forward.
And actually, let's call it backward, not back.
So the look forward function will simply say this
dot dot dot rotation equals to zero. So now if you
had to say dollar dot look forward, and call it,
as you can see, that all looks forward. And
if we were to call doll dot look backward,
so look backward, that doll will look at the
backwards backside. But now as you can see,
that doll rotates all of a sudden, but we want,
we want the doll to rotate slowly,
gradually, or animate. So for that,
we are going to use an animation library called G
SAP. So simply go to Google and search for G SAP.
And this is the official site of deception. So G
serve is a really powerful animation library for
Java scripts. So click on the get started here.
And from here, if we scroll down, as you can see,
this gives us a CDN link. So I'm going to
copy this link Ctrl C and paste it CTRL V.
So again, click CTRL S to save it, so to
save it as g sub dot main dot j s save. Okay,
now let's open up our sidebar again. And in the
JavaScript folder, as you can see, now we have
this G said dot min dot j, so let's add it to our
HTML also. So again, we're going to say script
source equals true, it will be j s forward slash
G SAP dot mean dot j s like so if we now save it,
there's close this tab. We don't need it anymore.
And let's close our sidebar by saying Ctrl B.
Now in the main dot j s, so here instead of saying
dollar dot rotation dot y equals to three point,
negative three point something, let me comment
this line out. And here instead of this we're
going to use the GCF. So here we're going to say
G dot To the object to the object we want is the
dollar rotation. And the property way we want to
animate is the y. So we're going to animate the
rotation dot y. So the rotation dot y should
go from zero to negative 3.15 in one second.
So that's, that's what we're doing by saying G
sub debt. So if we now save it, as you can see,
now, now that all enemies smoothly, so let's try
to see point four, five, so in 450 milliseconds,
now it takes 450 milliseconds for the doll
to rotate. So now let's do the same for the
forward function. So Ctrl C, and paste it here.
Here we enter, animate from negative 3.15 to zero,
like so. So now if we open up our console, and
call the dollar look forward function, it looks
forward, but it animates forward direction.
If we were to call the look backward function,
it looks backward, but But it's rotating
smoothly. So this is much better now. Okay,
now let's create the track that the player
have to cross. So let's say let's create a
function for that. So let's say function. And
let's call it create track. So create, track.
And create rec function will create the truck
to create the trip, we are going to use cube, so
we're going to use like three cubes. So to create
cubes, we know we have to do all these. So let's
create a utility function for that. So we're going
to say function, create cube, so create cube.
In this function, we can simply copy these codes.
So Control X and CTRL V. let me uncomment this
and fix the indentation, like so. Okay, now
let's try to call this create Q function in our
create drag function lives. So let's
me. So let's call that function here,
like so. And let's call the Create
rec function, also create trek.
If we now call the function and save it,
as you can see, now we have this cube.
Okay, let me comment out the code for the doll
for now. And now if we save it, as you can see,
we have this cube, but we don't want the queue
to be the size, we want to specify the size.
So let's see how we can do that. So let's again go
to the box geometry, so we can say box geometry.
So as you can see, when creating the geometry, we
can pass arguments so so we can pass the width,
the height and the depth of our cube. So
let's do that. So in the Create your function,
we are going to receive argument called
size. And when creating the box geometry,
we are going to pass the size dot height, we're
going to pass the size dot w for width, size dot h
for height, and size dot d for the depth. Okay,
now way we're calling the acuity function,
let's pass the size. So we're going to say
the width should be the width should be,
let's say, point two, so it will be a skinny
cube. And the height can be let's say, 1.5.
And the depth can be one. So let's say
d equals to one. So now if we save this,
this is how our cube looks like. But now we want
one cube to be on this side and one cube on this
side. So the function will also take a position.
So let's say position x, and inside the function,
we're going to say cube dot position dot x
equals to position x. So now in the function,
if we were to pass some position,
so let's say the position,
x can be, let's say three. Now it is in
this side, if we were to say negative three,
it will be on this side. Okay, let's create some
global variables. So I'm going to create global
variables here. So let's add a comment here,
specifying that were creating global variables
here. So let's say global variables. And we
are going to have one global variable for
start position. So here, let's say we are
going to have a variable called con start,
underscore post, underscore position. And
let's say the start position will be three
and the imposition will be negative three, or we
can say negative start pause for negative three,
like so. Actually, this should be in
position, so let's say in underscore position
like so now where we're calling the Create
Q function, we can pass the start position,
and if we save it, we got a cube on the on this
side, and we can also call this function again,
the same we're gonna pass the position
x as in position. Now we have one
now. Now we have one cube here, but now the
cube is kinda rotated. So let's fix that. So
let's say our create Q function will also take
a take argument called wrote x for rotation X.
And by default, it will be zero
like so. So now inside the body,
we can also say cube dot rotation dot x equals
to Vertex like so. So let's try to rotate it.
So let's try to rotate our cubes. So let's
say the first cubes rotations would be
let's try point four. Okay, Okay, so it looks
like their cube is being rotated in their own
axis. So let's fix that. So let's call it
y, and we want to rotate it rotate the Y.
And we're going to say
rotation dot y equals to what y
like so. So the saying point four is making it
even worse. So let's say negative point four. Now
it's looking much better. Let's try point
three. Let's try point three, five, actually.
And yeah, point three, five should be good enough
so and for the in, and for the second cube,
let's copy this, and this time, it will be
positive point three, five, like so Ctrl V,
and for this cube, the position x will be zero
in so it will be in the middle. So now we have
this cube here. So now we have this cube in the
middle. Let's also say rotation should be zero.
And for this one, let's say the width will be
starting position, times two. So if we do this,
we will have a cube that spans from the side to
the side. So let's give it a different color.
Okay, so let's say our creative function will
also take a color as this argument. So let's say
color. And the default color will be let's say, z
0x, and the hexadecimal value, so
the color I want is F, A, B, C 851.
So now, here, instead of saying color equals to
hashtag this color code, we are going to spot
I'm going to say this will be the color that we
pass in the while calling the function so color.
If we now save it, as you can see, now our cube
is this orange color. Okay, the cube is on top
of other cubes. So now create your function. Now,
we are also going to region the created cube, so
we are going to say return cube, like so. Okay, so
this is our biggest cube this one, so let me just
put it on top of other two. And now since we're
returning the cube where we can say this dot
position dot z equals two, and let's say the
position dot z will be negative one. So if we now
save it, this is how it looks. Okay, instead of
saying point one list, instead of saying negative
one list ending at point A. And point negative
point eight works perfect. And also for this one,
let's change the color. So there's past a color
here. So the color I have chosen is E five is 716.
So this is basically a darker orange color,
like so. So now Let's uncomment the noodle
function here. And it looks like the doll is
getting overlapped with the cube. So let's say
so let's say the position z will be
negative one. So if we now save it,
now it looks better. But now we have this gap.
So in so whereas specifying the width, let's
also add some more value here. So let's say point
two. So now it is spanning from starting position
to ending position like okay, now just like the
doll, let's create a class for our player, which
will be just a circle. So let's create a class
called player. So I'm going to say class player.
And in the constructor function, so let's
say constructor. So for the player when
to create a sphere, so let's go to the
documentation page and search for sphere.
And here is the sphere geometry. So let's copy the
codes Ctrl C, and we can paste them here. And now
instead of box geometry, we're using the sphere
geometry, the sphere geometry takes the radius,
the height segment and width segment, and
then we're creating the sphere with them
geometry and material like so. So
now let's save it go to our page.
Let's try to create a player so let's say const
player. So we are going to say const player.
If we now save it, we still can see the sphere.
That is because the sphere is too big. So let's
so let's say the radius
should be let's try just one.
So here is our sphere. This is
still too big. So let's say point
four. Or let's say point two. Or let's
say point three. And point you should
be good for the color. Let's try the
white color. So let's say fff FFF.
So now we have this white sphere. Now
the position of the sphere should be
in here. So let's say sphere dot position dot x.
So sphere, that position dot x equals to the start
position, like so now I want to create a function
called Run and if we call the run function,
the sphere should start moving so we're
going to create a function called Run.
Now before doing that, let's just say
this dot player so this dot player
equals to sphere and we also want
to know some info about the player.
So we are going to say these dot
info are these are Player Info.
These are Player Info will be our object. So here
we're again going to say and we're going to say
position x equals to start position. So basically,
where the sphere is currently, so currently the
sphere is here. So by saying position at x equals
to start position, we also want the velocity,
so we're going to say velocity. And we're going
to say the velocity should be zero. So velocity
is basically speed. So if the velocity is zero,
the sphere won't move. But if the velocity is one,
the sphere will move with a speed of one.
So we also want a function called Update.
And inside this function, first, we're
going to say this dot Player Info
dot position x plus equals to this dot Player
Info dot velocity, so keep increasing the players
position x. And then we're also going to say this
dot player dot position x equals to that this dot
equals to this dot player dot position
x. And we have to keep calling the update
function. So in the animate function here,
we were also going to say player dot update,
like so. But now the sphere is not moving. So
if we were to say the velocity is point 01,
now the sphere moves in that direction. So instead
of adding, let's abstract, so minus equals two.
And now as you can see, the
sphere moves in that direction.
But initially, we want the velocity to be
zero. And when we call the run function,
the velocity is, well city should increase
so we can say so in the run function,
we can say this dot player dot velocity equals
2.3. Point 03, like so. So if we save it, and then
if we open up the console, and call the player
dot run, so if we were to say player dot run.
As you can see, the sphere is moving, but we want
to call the run function, when we press our up
arrow key. So let's do that. So we are going to
use some event handling here. So we're going to
say window dot add EventListener. So we're
going to say window dot add event listener.
And we're going to listen for the key down event.
And here for now, they just say alert e dot key,
like so. So now if I were to press some key,
it enters the key if we press so if I were
to press the up arrow key, it says up arrow.
So here inside this function, we're going to
check if we press the up arrow. So we're going
to say if u dot key equals equals to arrow up.
If it is, then we want to call the player dot run
function. So we're going to say player dot run. So
now if I save it, and now press A, press the up
arrow, as you can see, the player starts moving,
but when I release my finger from the up arrow,
we want the player to stop running. So let's
create a function called stop. So here is our
question, let's create a function called stop.
So in this function, we are going to
say this dot Player Info dot velocity
equals to zero, so we're setting the velocities to
zero, so there is stop moving. So now we're also
going to listen for the key event. So copy this,
and here we are listening for the key up. So the
key down is when you press down arrow, and key up
is when you release that arrow. So inside here,
instead of calling the run function, we're
going to call the Stop function like so. So
if we now save it, and press our arrow key, it
starts moving. And if you release our arrow key,
it stops moving. Now, to make this a little bit
more interesting, what we can do is instead of
making the player stop, all of a sudden, we
can make it so it takes some time for the
player to stop. So we can do G sub the
two, we can say this dot Player Info,
and we want to animate the velocity. And let's
set the duration to be for now, let's say one,
like so. So if we press the arrow key, the ball
starts moving. But if we release that, okay, the
ball moves for a while and then stop. So this will
make the game even harder and more interesting.
But instead of duration to be one, one is too
long, let's say point one, so 100 milliseconds.
So it will take 100 millisecond for the player
to stop running, which will make the game a
little bit more interesting. And let's delete
this comment. We don't need it. Now I want to
show a text here. So let's create a text. So you
can create a text with three js as well. But I'm
going to use a regular HTML text. So I'm going
to have a paragraph text with a class of text.
And here we can say for now we're just loading
like so. So here is our text. Now you can see
the canvas is pushed down, but we want that
text to be on top of the canvas. So we're going
to say our text to have a position of thing. So
let's say dot text, to have a position of fixed.
And let's say they should have a
font size of let's try 50 pixel,
like so. And let's also say the font family to be
Arial. Like so let's say font weight will be bold,
font weight, bold, like so and Let's center it so
we can say lift to 50%. And we're also going to
go into say transform, it was to translate
X Translate X and it will be negative 50%.
So now if we save this, as you can see our text is
in the center and You can see our text is in the
center. So let's also say that top should be 10
pixels. So let's say top to be 10 pixels 10 pixel,
like So also you want some shadows. So let's say
text shadow. So let's say it takes the shadow,
and it says zero pixel from the x axis to
pixel from the y axis. dabbler can be five
pixel and lazy, let's use some dark colors to
say RGBA, 000. And opacity can be let's say,
point three, two, now, that takes us a little
bit more visible. Okay, now I want to create
a method in our doll doll class. So inside the
doll, I'm going to create a method called Start.
So start, what this method will do is that
also that all will look backward for some time,
then it will turn around and look forward for some
times and again, do the same. So let's do that. So
in the function, first thing we're going to do is
say look backwards. So let's say look backward,
so this dot look backward. And now we want the
doll to keep facing backward for some time. So
we want to use some delay here, or we want the
execution to be stopped for some some time. So
I'm going to create a function called delay. So
function called delay. And what this function will
do is take time as its argument, and then return
a promise that will resolve after the given time.
So we can use this to stop execution of our codes
for a while. So now we can make our Start function
asynchronous by saying async. And here we can say
our delay. And let's say we want to delay for one
second. And after one second, we want this to look
forward to we're going to say this, look forward,
and then I can do a delay. So we're again going
to say our delay, and let's say 1000 seconds also.
And then we're going to call the dessert start
function. So this dot start. So as you can see,
this is a recursive function. Okay, so now in the
set timeout, so why is the set timeout instead of
saying dollar dot look backward, we can say dollar
dot start. So if we were to say dollar strat,
you'll see, that all looks backwards for a second
then turns around and looks forward for a second,
like so. But instead of saying, once again,
once again, we can use a random number. So
this will make the game more hard and less
predictable. So let's do that. So let's say
the time should be math dot
random, so we're going to say math.
So we're going to say math dot
random, and we're going to say
1000 seconds, this will give us a number
between zero to 1000. And if we were to add,
and if we were to add 1000 to eight. Now we'll
get an, we'll get a number between 1000 to
2000. So that all will look backward for one
second to two seconds. So if we now save it,
that all looks backward for a random amount of
time, we can do the same for the look forward.
So let's copy this Ctrl C and paste
it here. So this time, let's say 750
to 700, and plus 750. So this will look forward
for 750 milliseconds to 1.5 seconds, save.
And now the dog looks at forward and backward for
a random amount of time. So this is more hard and
predict unpredictable for the US player. So
now our dog looks at forward and backward
for an amount of time, and we can press the
arrow key to move out there. So now we're
ready to implement the game logic. So first,
I'm going to create a function called init.
That will initialize the game. So let's create
a function called in it. This will also be an
asynchronous function. So async. So here first,
what we'll do is delay will use our delay and will
delay for let's say, 500 millisecond. And after
that, that takes should say, starting in three
after some time that takes should settle starting
into studying in one and then go so first,
let's target our texts or TextEdit class of text
to let's create that. So let's say const text
equals to document dot query selector and our
text had a class of text. So dot txt takes like
so now let's go to our init function. And inside
the function, let's say takes dot inner text
equals two, we're going to say starting.
So starting in three, like so. So now
let's call the init function. So in a save,
and as you can see, now it says starting in
threes, so let me copy this three more times.
So after 500 milliseconds, we'll say starting in
two, and after that, it will say starting in one,
and then it will say study, and then
it will say go, so the game will start.
Save it as it as you can see, say starting in
321, go and after that, we're going to call a
function called Start Game. So start game.
And let's create that function. So function
start game. So inside that function, we're
going to call the dollar dot start. So let's,
let's delete this now. And we're going to call
the dollar start here. So we'll say dollar dot
start. So now if we save it, as you can see
it says loading 321 And after that, that all
starts moving around or turning around whatever
you want to say. Okay, now let's also show our
progress bar. So the progress bar will just be
a cube. So I'm going to say let progress bar,
because we are going to again call our cue
function. So create cube, so create cube. And for
the Create cube, the width will be let Fave eight,
the height will be, let's say one. So height
equals to actually, let's say point one, and the
depth will be one, like so. So if we save it,
we have some error. That is because you also
have to pass a position. So let's say position
x should be zero, save it, okay, this should be
d equals to one, a depth equals to one, save it.
So now we have this progress bar here, okay, the
weight is too much. So let's say which, which
would be five. Here is our progress bar we and
the progress bar to be in the top. So let's say.
So we're going to say progress bars are
positioned at y equals 3.35. If we save it,
as you can see here is our progress. But now
we need to make it functional. So as time
goes by, we the progress bar should decrease.
So let's create another constant. So let's
go to our variables here. And let's create
a constant. So we'll say const time limit
so that this will when the time limit
for our game. So time underscore limit.
Let's say that time limit should be 10 Second,
and now in the Start function, where is the start
function? Let's find it out. So here is our start
function so that we can again use the G SAP so we
can say G SAP dot two, and we want to animate
our progress bar, so let's say progress bar
dot scale, so we're going to say dot
scale. So we're going to set the scale
x to zero in the time limit are in
10 seconds. So if we now save it,
as you can see, the progress bar starts
shrinking down. Also, we can specify easing
function here. So we can say is equals to
none to be linear, like so. So save it.
And now the progress bar moves, okay, one thing
you will notice is the player can start moving
even before the game is started. So like, as
you can see, I can move before the game he has
started, so we don't want that. So let's create
a variable called Game stat for game status.
So in our variables here, we're going to say
const. Game stat for game status or game stat.
So initially, the game stat will be loading, copy
this and let's go to our event listeners here. So
we are inside the if we're going to say if game
stat to game stat is not equals to start it
then we don't want to do anything.
So we're simply going to say return.
So now if I press the arrow key, as you can
see, the ball does not move to inside the
Start function here is the start game, we can say
game stat equals to start it. So game stat equals
true started. But I just realized that since we're
reassigning to a constant, we'll it will give us
some error. So let's go back to our variables
here. Instead of saying cost it will be late,
like so. So now once the game is started, we
can press the arrow key to move like so. So now,
we pretty much have everything ready to go. Now
we just have to implement again logic. Okay,
so now in the Player class, where is that so let's
find it here is our player layer class, we were
going to create another function called stick.
This will take the if the winner has crossed
the board or if the winner has lost. So basically,
inside the update function, we can call the check
function. So let's say check this dot check. And
since in the animation loop where keep calling
the update function, the check function will be
also called again and again. So now what we want
to do is check if the door is facing forward
and the velocity of our velocity of our player
is not equals to zero, that means the player
was moving when the door was looking forward,
that means the player has lost. So let's try to
do that. So first, we need to create a variable.
So let's create a variable called Create is
looking backward, so is looking backward.
So by default, it could be true. So let's say
true, it should be Easter looking backwards,
like so. So once that all looks backward, we want
this to be true. Once I looked all looks forward,
we want this to be false. So let's see
how we can do that. So let me copy this.
Inside the dual class, we have this look forward
and look backward button. Let me delete this,
we don't need it. As you can see, it takes 450
milliseconds for the URL to look backward. So we
can do a set timeout. So we can say set timeout.
And we're going to run this function after
450 milliseconds and after 450 millisecond what we
can do is say is looking backward equals to true.
And let me copy this and let's paste it so Ctrl V,
so here we want to say looking backward equals to
false. Okay, but even if the doll rotates just a
little bit, we should be able to move so instead
of saying 457 Just say 150. So if the door has
rotated just a little bit, we are free to move,
like so save. Now let's go to the players check
function. So in the check function, we're going
to say if player, so we're going to say this dot
Player Info, Player Info dot velocity, so velocity
is greater than zero. And that doll is
looking forward. So we're going to say
if exclamation mark is dog looking backward.
That means if the doll is looking forward,
in that case, we can say we can finally just say
Are you lost. Okay, now let's try to play it.
So as you can see, when we try to move when the
dog is looking forward, we lose so it is working.
And in the check function, we we also want to
check if the player has successfully crossed
this line. So if the player's position
x is greater than the ending position,
that means the player has won. So let's say if
layer dot position dot x is less than Indian
position that then will say you want so let's
comment this out for now. And let's try to move
and as you can see, it says you in
after your position dot x is here,
so And because we said the balls X to one that
the ball had to cross a little more space for
then the Starting Angle. So instead of saying
we'll same position that x is less than this,
we can say position x is less than this
last point for like so unless try to move.
So now as you can see, once we crossed
this line, which it says you won't,
so now we can uncomment this, so control forward
slash uncomment. Okay, let's try to play it.
Okay, it looks like we have a little bit of
error. Let's fix that. So in this function
we have missed up in the loop backward function,
this should say 150. And this one should say 456.
Instead, like so. So save it.
Let's try to play it one more time.
It says you lose. Let's play one once more.
And as you can see, if we've successfully
crossed the crack, it says you win.
Now instead of alert, what we want to do is,
as you can see, if I try to see if I say okay,
that will keep coming. That is because that check
function is being called again and again. So if
the player wins and lose wins or lose, what we're
going to do is say game state equals two over.
And now let's go to the animation frame here is
our animation stream. So we're going to say if
game state equals equals two, so game state
equals equals two over, we're going to return
so we don't want to this function to be called
ever again. So like so Okay, so let's save it.
And now let's try to run it. So once you
lose, it says a lot zero in this and now we
can close it. And once you lose, you cannot move
forward anymore. Okay, now let's make the test
text say you in if we and say lose if you
lose, so let's do that. So let's go to our
check function. Here, we're going to say text
dot inner text equals two. So text dot inner text
equals two, you lose. And here we can say,
text dot inner text equals three, you win.
So let's try to run it.
Okay, let's delete the alerts,
we don't need the alerts anymore.
As you can see, if we try to move it
says you lose. So let's try to win now.
And now it says you want another thing we have to
take a lease. But if the player runs out of time,
if he runs out of time when you
say time over, so let's do that.
So inside the Start function, so
let's go to the Start function.
Here, we're also going to do a set
timeout. So we're going to say set timeout,
like so. And we're going to time run the function
after that time limit is over. So a DC time limit,
times 1000. That is because our time limit is
10, which is in second but that set timeout takes
time in milliseconds. That is why we were
multiplying it with 100. So after that,
we're going to say we're going to say
if the game state is not equals to over
that means the player have run out of time, but
he couldn't clear this track. So we're going to
say x dot inner text equals to let's say you ran
you ran out of time so you you ran out of time
Okay now let's see what
happens if we run out of time
as you can see it says you ran
out of time and we cannot move
any more we can do anything but if we refresh
we can play again so let's try to play
oopsie we lost let's try to play one more time
we have lost again let's try one
more time this time I'm going to win
Oh no, I have lost again.
Let's try one one last time
and then we have won the game.
So now everything is working
as intended. So now we have successfully
created the red light green light game
from squeaking. I hope you enjoyed
this video and you have created
yourself as well. Don't forget to like
and subscribe and I'll see you next time.